>> I'd like to
welcome Cynthia Dwork
to our Fireside Chat today
and to your MSR AI
distinguished lecture
coming up in the next hour.
Cynthia is the Gordon
McKay professor
at Harvard University,
the Radcliffe
alumnae professor at
the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study,
and affiliated faculty
at Harvard Law,
as well as a
distinguished scientist
at Microsoft Research. Welcome.
>> Thank you. It's
good to be here.
>> I wanted to start
off with thinking about
your background of the breadth of
topics you've worked on
in Computer Science.
I wanted to ask you, how you
got into Computer Science,
and then how you
chose the problems,
the breadth, the
problems that you've
worked on from cryptography
to privacy and now fairness.
>> So that's a broad question.
I got into Computer Science
initially on a lark.
When I was applying to
college my mother said,
"Maybe you should consider
applying to the
engineering school."
I was applying to Princeton.
I said, "Why not?"
I checked the box.
So, I started in
Computer Science.
At that time, it was electrical
engineering and Computer Science.
I pretty much liked
my first year.
I started the circuits course
in my second year and
I didn't like it,
and I switched out of
the School of Engineering
and wouldn't come back until
they waived the requirement
for the circuits course.
Then, in junior year,
I met formal languages in
Automata theory and
I just fell in love.
When I was ready to graduate,
I decided I wanted to continue
my studies and I went to
Cornell and studied theory.
My first work was in
distributed computing.
I did that for a number of years.
I was heavily influenced
by Nancy Lynch,
who had come from MIT to give
a talk when I was
a graduate student at Cornell.
I postdoced for her.
At a certain point,
we needed, well, so in
distributed computing,
you're often talking about
good guys computing in
the presence of
some bad guys that are
trying to disrupt
the computation.
It's very natural
that you might use
cryptography to hide
information from the bad guys.
What we discovered was that the
kinds of cryptography
that existed,
the cryptography that captured
privacy from
a passive eavesdropper,
when messages are
going back and forth,
is not the same as
what you needed when
the adversary is playing
the same game as all
of the good guys.
So, we needed basically a
different kind of cryptography.
So, I ended up studying
cryptography and I got into,
developed something called
Non-Malleable Cryptography,
together with Moni Naor
and Danny Dolev.
Then I loved crypto,
and I did that for
quite some time,.
Eventually, around the year 2000,
I was talking to the philosopher
Helen Nissenbaum,
who studies philosophical issues
that arise in the context
of new technologies.
Nissenbaum was studying what does
privacy mean in public and what
does privacy mean when we
have video cameras
all over the place?
I got very intrigued.
I looked for a piece of
the privacy puzzle that
theoretical Computer Science
and cryptography might
be able to say something about.
Crypto had devolved a lot of
language for talking about
partial information and that
seemed like a good beginning,
and that is how I
got into privacy
and led to differential
privacy eventually.
>> That's fascinating.
So these topics that
you've been working on
from both privacy and
then now fairness,
these are age old
problems, right?
That philosophers, ethicists,
and the legal scholars
have been thinking
about for centuries,
and now you've brought,
I think a very new perspective,
the Computer Science, a
theoretical perspective.
I'm curious, since
you've been doing that,
how has that
perspective, you think,
shaped or affected the broader
discussion about privacy
and now how people are
thinking about fairness?
>> So I don't think that
what we've done in privacy
preserving data analysis really
addresses large questions about
how people feel about privacy.
It was a very specific corner
of the general privacy puzzle.
We did look a bit to
the legal and the
philosophical literature,
to help us try to articulate
specific privacy concerns,
meaning legal scholars and
philosophers will try to find
very precise language to
capture things that people
feel and why they
feel the way they do.
So, we got help from them
more than vice versa.
In the fairness domain,
I think that there is
some chance that
the data analytic tools
can help shine spotlight on how
people think and where there
are unfairnesses and biases.
So, we may get
some help on the bigger
questions from the technology.
So, I love that,
you've mentioned
the interplay between
Computer Science and
other disciplines
and borrowing ideas from them,
and now, perhaps feeding back a
little as well and trying to
figure out the solutions to
these challenges together.
How do you go about engaging with
people outside of
our home discipline?
How do I go about it?
So, I guess research,
like any other kind of research.
So, usually there's
some sort of starting point,
like in the privacy domain,
my interest was
piqued by Nissenbaum.
In other areas in fairness,
I could start
immediately looking for
people who think about questions
of distributive justice,
who think about gender
bias in medicine,
who think about racial bias.
When you have some successful
conversations with people,
they're kind and refer
you to their friends.
So, I've been tremendously
lucky and had
the opportunity to talk to
a lot of people this way.
So, networking I guess,
>> Yes.
>> -and reading.
A lot of reading.
>> Do you think
Computer Science as a whole,
does enough of this type
of engagement or just
the right amount? I'm curious.
>> So I think that
Computer Scientists,
more than ever, have
to start thinking
about ethics, and being
educated about ethics.
That Computer Science is
moving into a position
of tremendous power,
and with that comes
ethical responsibilities.
At the same time,
everybody has his or her own
strengths and interests,
and for the people who only
want to study one
kind of thing deeply,
I certainly wouldn't
want to derail them.
So, I think naturally,
we're going to have a big mix.
But I do feel that students
should be educated about ethics.
Harvard is moving in
that direction in
Computer Science as well.
So, I had an ethicist
come and speak and
work with the class,
in the class that I
taught most recently,
and several other people
are doing this.
>> When we were talking
earlier this morning,
you mentioned that you
thought that the work you're
doing now in bias
is a lot more
challenging in some ways
than your earlier work
on differential privacy.
I'm curious if you
could say a little
bit more about that.
>> Sure. So, I
think that defining bias
is much, much tougher.
So, the first thing
that you want to do,
if you want to have
a technical solution
that helps with at least some
aspect of a bias problem,
is to define what bias is,
or to define what is the
unfairness that you're trying
to combat in
your particular corner
of the technological universe.
So, when we were talking about
privacy and we had narrowed it
down to privacy preserving
data analysis,
which is a much smaller scope
than privacy in general.
We could think about different
definitions of privacy,
and we came up with one
which is rather robust,
and it captures many intuitions
about what constitutes
privacy in data analysis.
So, you come up with it,
you develop methods
that insure it,
and there's not controversy
about what you're doing.
It may or may not do everything,
but it does what it says it does,
and people don't argue that
what it says it's
doing is a bad thing,
it's only a good thing.
Now, when it comes to fairness,
things go all over the place.
So, for example, you
could say, "Well,
I want to have a classifier and I
want to ensure what we
called demographic parity."
That is the number,
the fraction of
people in a given demographic
group that are, let's say,
receiving a positive
classification,
should be the same
as this fraction of
the demographic group in
the population as a whole.
Is that fair or isn't it?
Is affirmative action
fair or isn't it?
If you are looking
at cases where you're
trying to make predictions,
and you're going
to have some error
because the future
is not knowable,
do you require
equal false positive rates
and false negative rates
across groups or not?
What are the consequences
of these things?
So, a lot of natural definitions,
natural desiderata, are
mutually exclusive.
What do you do about that?
What can you ask
your system to do when
these various things that you
want are mutually exclusive?
You have to come to some kind of
a social agreement as to
what you mean by fair,
and what's appropriate
for your setting.
I'm starting to understand
that this is a fundamentally
political process.
My politics education
is just beginning.
>> So do you think the role
of the language and
framework theory
behind fairness is about
showing the options to
policymakers and legal folks,
or what role do you see?
>> Okay. So, first of all,
I should mention there is
a definition that I like,
although it too has
all sorts of problems.
The definition that
I like is what
we're calling,
individual fairness.
Which says intuitively that,
if given a particular
classification task,
individuals who are
similar with respect to
that classification task should
be classified similarly,
should have similar
probabilities of
positive classification,
for example.
Of course, the problem
with that is, well,
how do we determine who is
similar to whom for this task?
What is the metric?
What is the measure
of distance of
similarity or dissimilarity
between two people?
Even if you had
your hands on a metric,
how do you know that
it's the right one?
So, an example that
I like to think
about is, let's say that,
we have a very nice
news organization
and we are looking to
hire people to
our news organization.
So, we want to
predict who is likely
to succeed at
the news organization,
and we have a very crisp
definition of success.
You stay three years with
the company at least,
and you have at least one
promotion in those three years.
So, success is well-defined.
So, then you want
to say, somehow,
that if you have
two people who are similarly
likely to succeed,
then they should have
the same probabilities
of getting a job offer,
or similar probabilities
of getting the job offer.
So now let's change
the problem and we say, well,
maybe it's not such a
nice news organization,
maybe it's a news
organization that
has historically been
hostile to women.
So now, for two equally
talented individuals,
one male and one female,
it may be that the man
is more likely to
succeed than the woman because
the atmosphere is hostile.
So, wait, should the metric be
capturing likelihood of success
or should the metric
in fact be talent?
In the nice news organization,
talent predicts your success.
In the nasty news organization,
talent is insufficient
to predict success.
So, you need to
exercise thought and
judgment about what should
the classifiers be doing
and how do you use them?
On the other hand,
when you actually
formalize the problem,
it becomes abundantly clear that
the issue is hostility
in the work environment.
So, there's something
that's gained
immediately from the
formalization of the problem.
>> So you brought up the issue
of these algorithms,
accidentally learning from
society's biases and
amplifying them,
potentially in the decisions
that they make.
That's one source of bias
I hear people talking
about but might
also hear people talking
about data biases,
where the data that's used
to train an algorithm is
perhaps an insufficient
representation
of what goes in the world.
Maybe it's bias through
some selection mechanism
or collection mechanism.
Do you see these
two types of biases
as two sides of the same coin
or do you think that they
are different and require
different approaches to address?
>> So I'm not actually
clear what you
mean in your first example.
In fact, when you were
saying your first example,
I thought that you
meant the second.
That is, that the biases
are imbibed in the mother's milk
of the training data.
Then, what's learned,
it's not an accident
that it's learned.
It wasn't the intention of
the algorithm designer to teach
the algorithm to be
biased but the biases are
just brought in there from
the historical training data.
>> So I was thinking
about the two kinds
of biases, I was thinking about,
was one where there is
an existing bias in
an organization like
the company versus another one
where the organization
is not biased but
perhaps the data that
you collected about
employee success was selected in
such a way to not be representative
of that organization.
>> So clearly, a biased
organization is giving
rise to what I would call
biased historical data.
So probably, if I'm
interpreting your question
correctly, the answer is yes.
These are two sides
of the same coin.
>> Yeah. I guess in
one case you have
opportunities to go and collect
more data and the other one
you can't without
fixing others section.
>> So you're alluding
to something else which
is just lack of representation.
Lack of representation presents
its own problems and
historically has
presented bad problems.
One can collect more data
and one can also
be smarter about
exploration-exploitation trade-offs.
So, there's starting to be
a nice literature on this thing
in the fair algorithms world.
But I think also that,
if I'm not mistaken,
economists were
also aware of this.
So, you have two populations,
a minority population and
a majority population.
You know the majority very well.
What kinds of incentives can you
offer a bank for giving loans to
the minority populations so
that population
becomes better known.
So, these questions
are not entirely new.
These questions of lack of
representation are not
entirely new and I think
we should be thinking
a lot in terms
of what sorts of things
can we do to encourage
the increasing of the data sets
and balancing out,
so that we get
much more informed views.
How do we bring in experts on
different populations
and include them in
the discussion of what
constitutes fair,
and what are
the right criteria to
be using for
the different groups?
I know that there is
some interest in having,
say classifiers that suppressed
the information of
the demographic group.
My guess is, well not my guess,
we know specifically that
there are situations
in which doing
this leads to reduced utility
that having context allows
you to make better judgments.
>> Where do you see
the future lies in fairness?
Do you think that will
make significant headway
in the next few years from
either practical or theoretical
point of view or do you think
that it's a long ways off yet?
Given the politics and
the social aspects of
challenges or the problem.
>> I think real progress on
the mathematical side
will be relatively rapid.
That I'm seeing just in
the last couple of years,
a real gathering of strength
and a plethora of new ideas
and variations on the definitions
that try to bridge the individual
versus the group in
very exciting ways.
There are also some extremely
intriguing approaches
coming up in the deep
learning community.
So, I think that this
is going really well.
I don't believe there will be
an alternative to
having discussions that
bring in politics and ethics
and economics and so on.
I think that the charges to
these communities are going
to go up and you're going to say,
we need help with this
that and the other thing.
So, I think things
will make progress,
but I don't see
yet our way to finding
a single crisp definition
of what fair is,
that will really capture
what we want all the
time from an algorithm,
a fair algorithm, and that will
behave very well under
what we call composition.
We haven't spent any time talking
about these very
important questions of,
if you have a system
that has a bunch
of pieces each of which is fair,
what can you say about fairness
of your system in
total altogether?
In other scenarios, in
cryptography and in
differential privacy people
know how to talk about
composition and ensure
nice composition properties.
But in the fairness domain,
things are much more
difficult and we
get initial results are
very negative and we
have to work hard to
ensure fairness together.
>> That's good to hear.
I think we're out of time
and your talk is to
be coming up soon.
Thank you very much
Cynthia for coming.
It's been a pleasure
talking with you.
The pleasure it's been
mine. Thank you so much.